[Music]
the job of being a hedge fund manager is
often met with a lot of controversy it
seems like their jobs are not only
boring but also lack meaning they
generally work 80 to 100 hours per week
for decades just to make their clients
richer and then there's also the whole
manipulation side of things that many
despise even some of the highest profile
figures in the world like elon musk have
knocked down the idea of being a fund
manager but despite the criticism hedge
fund managers are some of the highest
paid individuals in the world often
earning hundreds of millions if not
billions per year and the man who topped
the list in 2020 was a man named izzy
englander who pulled in a whopping 3.8
billion dollars his flagship fund was up
26 last year which was their strongest
performance in 20 years meanwhile second
place went to the famous jim simons who
earned over a billion dollars less at
2.6 billion so here's how easy englander
beat out even the most iconic managers
in the world and became the world's
highest paid hedge fund manager
taking a look back izzy was born in 1948
in brooklyn to a jewish migrant family
his parents were originally from poland
but they moved to the us in 1947 after
they were extradited to a soviet labor
camp following world war ii you could
say that his parents left everything
behind to come to the u.s but the sad
truth was that there was nothing left
for them in poland in the first place
all of izzy's father's family and much
of his mother's family were killed
during the holocaust despite all the
pain and discrimination the family had
gone through because of their religion
the family remained to devout jews and
that's still the case with izzy to this
day
anyway izzy developed a strong interest
in the stock market from a rather young
age by the time he was in high school he
was already trading stocks in his free
time daisy would go on to attend a new
york university where he majored in
finance and after graduation in 1970 he
found a job at the wall street firm
kaufman alzberg and co
his job at kaufman consisted of trading
convertible securities and options which
were new financial instruments at the
time
as many of y'all probably know options
are extremely volatile and can move
hundreds of percent in a day so this job
really taught izzy how to be extremely
disciplined and to manage risk in the
meantime izzy enrolled in nyu's mba
program and attended classes in the
evenings but he never ended up
completing the program as he would get
distracted by an opportunity
you see around the same time the
american stock exchange also began to
list options and izzy would go ahead and
buy a seat on the exchange this allowed
izzy to create his own floor brokerage
house called ia englander and koa and
that brings us into izzy's first
business
ia englander and co was just a simple
brokerage that allowed customers to buy
and sell stocks and bonds while it was
nothing groundbreaking the company was
profitable and it's actually still
around to this day izzy still even holds
his stake in the company but he's not
involved in day-to-day operations anyway
after running this company for several
years izzy would start an investment
firm called the jaime securities and co
with a man named john mohren jr in 1985
but this business wasn't nearly as
smooth as the first
in the beginning though it looked like
things were going great as the bellsburg
family would invest 75 million dollars
into the company the problem though was
that jon had a dark past that would come
to haunt him before opening the business
with izzy john used to work for a man
named ivan bowsky who would end up being
convicted for insider trading
boski said he would plead guilty and
would cooperate with federal authorities
in a widening investigation of insider
trading ivan would testify against john
in return for a reduced sentence and
john would end up being convicted for
aiding in insider trading izzy wasn't
associated with this incident but given
all of the bad press jon had garnered
for the company izzy had no choice but
to shut it down
by this point izzy had become quite
wealthy thanks to his first two
businesses and he would use this money
to start up millennium management with
ronald shearer in 1989. izzy put in five
million dollars of his own money and the
bellsburg family would put in another
two million dollars once again though
the company would get off to a rough
start and ronald would leave the company
just one year later in 1990 but izzy
wasn't willing to start over again so he
would continue nonetheless
in terms of growing millennium
management and generating profits gazia
leveraged three key strategies with the
first being convertible arbitrage a
convertible security is usually a
corporate bond or preferred stock of a
given company that can be converted into
regular stock with a convertible
arbitrage fund managers are looking for
discrepancies in price between
convertible securities and common stock
for example maybe tesla preferred stock
is trading at one thousand dollars while
the common stock is trading at one
thousand and five dollars the idea is
that the gap will close and that both
securities will eventually trade for the
same price in such a scenario the
funding manager will buy the preferred
stock at one thousand dollars and short
the common stock at one thousand and
five dollars if you look closely you'll
notice that this leaves the manager with
no directional bias
it doesn't matter if tesla doubles
tomorrow or if it crashes eighty percent
as long as the discrepancy between the
preferred and common stock remains five
dollars the manager loses no money by
eliminating directional bias managers
are able to heavily reduce risk but that
doesn't mean that there's no risk if the
discrepancy between the two securities
grows you start to lose money fast as
you're bleeding money from both sides
this is extremely rare but it has
happened before
one example of this was with the gm
stock in 2005. at the time many hedge
funds had long positions in gm
convertible bonds and short positions in
gm stock but suddenly gm stock was
downgraded which caused their
convertible bonds to crash in value
you would think that the stock would
also follow suit but a billionaire
investor was actively buying the dip
which propped up the stock price and
made the disparity explode so clearly
things can go bad but in most cases
convertible arbitrage is an easy way to
capitalize on pricing discrepancies with
low risk moving on to easy second
strategy we have statistical arbitrage
similar to convertible arbitrage
statistical arbitrage aims to leverage
price discrepancies this time the goal
is to leverage the discrepancy between
the market and an individual stock or
industry unless a stock receives some
crazy news or has a killer earnings
report it follows the overall market now
a stock may be more volatile than the
market but this can also be measured by
something called beta for example for
every one percent the s p 500 rises you
may be able to expect tesla to rise five
percent barring any elon tweets but what
if the market is up one percent and
tesla is also only up one percent
in this scenario it's statistically
likely that tesla will rise another four
percent so it would be a relatively safe
bet to buy tesla stock
similarly if the market is only up one
percent but tesla is up nine percent
it's statistically likely that tesla
will drop four percent and it would be a
safe fed to short tesla stock
statistical arbitrage looks to leverage
such over and under performances of the
market to squeeze out some profits and
finally moving on to ac's third key
strategy we have fundamental long and
short pairing this is really the bread
and butter of all hedge funds you go
ahead and buy some stocks and short some
other stocks at the same time this
reduces your overall exposure to the
market some funds employ neutral
strategies where they have an equal
amount in long and short positions while
other funds utilize long biases which
means that they have more and long
positions there's really nothing unique
or special about this strategy but being
a hedge fund izzy often finds themselves
leveraging this strategy as well
[Music]
in terms of trading philosophies izzy
only has a few simple guidelines but
these have proven extremely valuable for
him his first rule for trading is
maintaining severe risk control when
you're playing with tens of billions of
dollars this should really be a given
but it's not uncommon to hear about
hedge fund managers taking outsized bets
and getting destroyed so clearly
sticking to risk guidelines is not as
easy as it sounds moving on to ac second
rule we have be committed to
non-directional strategies as we saw
with all of these trading strategies
none of them depended on the market
going up or down in fact the direction
of the market had no impact on izzy's
performance and this is extremely
important because the hardest part isn't
making money in a bull market or a bear
market but making money in a sideways
market and finally moving on to ac's
last rule we have a warren buffett type
role which is never forget to observe
their first two rules
applying these strategies and
philosophies over 30 years has allowed
millennium management to rock it from 35
million in 1999 to 57 billion assets
today making them one of the largest
hedge funds in the world
they currently operate a total of 200
different investment teams and employ 2
800 people if you're thinking about
getting a job here though you better be
extremely tough as employment and
compensation are strictly dependent on
individual quarterly performance
millennium management along with the
rest of wall street has received massive
criticism for these high-pressure work
environments but despite how the media
paints them people continue to flock
towards these companies because the
upside potential is extraordinary as for
easy englander today he spends a lot of
his effort on supporting the jewish
community as much as possible since 2006
the englander foundation has donated a
total of 20 million dollars most of
which has gone to jewish schools and
organizations izzy hasn't been shy and
splurging on himself either in 2014 for
instance he bought a duplex in new
york's park avenue for a whopping 71.3
million dollars which is a record price
for a manhattan co-op at the end of the
day izzy's life matches the hedge fund
stereotype pretty well he's made his
fortune on leveraging municipal price
discrepancies in the market but despite
making so much money it's not clear what
sort of legacy and impact millennium
really has on the world you could argue
that izzy is just really good at a
zero-sum game but that he's not really
creating any real value regardless of
these critiques though it seems like
izzy is enjoying his life just fine and
in the end that's all that really
matters would you guys consider becoming
a hedge fund manager comment that down
below also drop a like if you wish you
had a billion dollar salary and of
course consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing and see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys